hey
why do we have uppercase and lowercase
letters in english
most of you are probably thinking that
the answer is obvious you learn the uses
of the two cases in like first grade
right uppercase letters are used to
start sentences and are used at the
start of names and proper nouns
lowercase letters are used for
everything else
ok sure we all know how grammatically
the two cases are used in english but
did you know that not all writing
systems have upper and lower cases
or that even other languages that use
the latin alphabet have different rules
for capitalization
for instance german capitalizes the
first letters of all nouns whether
proper or
improper
is that what you call normal nouns
right so back to the question why do we
use two cases well let's find out
[Music]
originally the latin alphabet was a
magical script
which is a fancy way of saying that it
had no lowercase letters
these letters are now called roman
square capitals because of their blocky
nature they're basically the capital
letters we know today
these square capitals were not the only
way latin was written however
these blocky letters with their straight
lines and basic curves worked best when
carved into stone
when romans wrote on paper or papyrus or
whatever they used roman cursive
this script is more rounded as it was
faster to write when writing with a
quill as opposed to a hammer and chisel
as you can see some of our lowercase
letters are starting to show themselves
but this is only the beginning of the
story the cursive letters weren't used
in tandem with the capitals
and they weren't consistent either
roman cursive inspired the later
lowercase script but the alphabet had a
lot of evolving to do before we get to
the 2k system we know today
after the fall of the western roman
empire spoken latin gave way to various
romance languages in the old roman
territories
that said written latin was still very
much used and would continue to be the
preferred language of writing for
hundreds of years
but latin had no case system so the
scripts that were created in the middle
ages to write latin had no concept of
lower or uppercase writing
we won't go through a comprehensive
history of latin script types because
the subject is vast and would be way too
long
i mean look at this chart showing a
simplified relationship between the
different scripts through to the modern
day
we'll only tackle a few of these the
ones that have the most bearing on
answering our question
the first script we'll look at is the
unseal script
it was used throughout europe in the 4th
century through to the 8th century
it was a magiscool script but since it
was written on parchment or vellum it
used curves much like roman cursive with
this script you can start to really see
the evolution from the roman capitals to
our lower case letters the letters a d h
m and e
are all in the middle of transforming
the unseal script and its derivations
were extremely popular with scribes
throughout europe famous manuscripts
like the book of kells were written
using the script
the most important version of the unseal
script as it pertains to answering the
question posed in this video was the
semi or half unseal
despite its name this script was not an
evolution of the unseal script but
instead shared a common ancestor to the
unseal script that being new roman
cursive
half unseal was the first major
minuscule script
so we should properly define the terms
magiskool and minuscule they don't just
mean uppercase and lowercase magical
letters are defined by being of a
uniform height for instance a capital a
is the same as a b or c and so on
minuscule letters however have variable
heights
the lowercase q or p has a descender
here and an h has an ascender here while
letters like e or a
have no such protrusions
okay cool so with the half on seals we
almost have our lowercase script but
there's an issue here you see half
unseal was its own script it wasn't used
in tandem with capital letters
no scripts at this point were bicameral
meaning using two cases
that was until carolingian minuscule the
carolingian script is thought to have
been created or at least finalized by
alkwin of york an english monk and
scribe who was invited to teach at the
court of charlemagne hence the name
carolingian
it was used during the 8th and 9th
centuries in france during the period
known as the carolingian renaissance
that's right there were renaissances
before the renaissance that we all know
anyway during this time scribes in the
court of charlemagne and his successors
copied a lot of roman documents that
were fading or falling apart to preserve
the texts
this point will become important later
so the carolingians used both this new
minuscule script and also capitals
reminiscent of the old unsealed letters
they use these capitals for titles as
well as for important words
the practice of using large decorative
letters to start a page or sentence had
become a common practice when making
manuscripts for instance here is an
example of that in the book of dura the
carolingians were the first known to
take this decorative practice and turn
it into something systematized with more
or less consistent rules
skipping forward about 700 years we come
to the renaissance humanists
the humanists were a group of secular
thinkers who rejected what they saw as a
superstitious backwards medieval world
why do we call them an evil period the
dark ages blame the humanists they were
interested in a revival of roman ideals
in art architecture literature and yes
even in typography
they weren't fans of the dominant script
of the time
black letter this script sometimes
incorrectly called gothic is probably
what you think of when imagining
medieval writing it took over from the
carolinging script and was used for
hundreds of years throughout europe it
was even used in places like germany and
denmark into the 19th century
black letter is a very important part of
the history of western typography but
since it doesn't directly contribute to
the question posed in this video we'll
skip its origins
the point is the humanists wanted
something different so they went
searching and what did they find
what's this
wow original roman manuscripts they said
look at how elegant and classic this
lettering is surely much more
sophisticated than this medieval gothic
hand of course the humanists didn't
realize that what they had found was not
actually roman writing but instead
copies of roman manuscripts made by the
carolingian monks in the carolingian
script regardless the humanists created
their own minuscule inspired by the very
medieval carolingian script and combined
it with romanesque square capitals
replacing the ornate gothic capitals
used before this style of writing is
essentially what is used today
so there you go from roman capitals
through unseals carolingian and finally
humanist scripts we get our two case way
of writing
a couple more things before we wrap up
one printing in the 15th century
johannes gutenberg created the first
printing press which sparked the
printing revolution
the printing press worked through
movable type there were two pieces of
type for each letter
the minuscule letters were kept in a
drawer closer to the printer as these
sorts were used more frequently the
capital letters were kept in a case
above the main working station so the
terms lower case for minuscules and
uppercase for capitals were established
lastly while bicameral writing had been
used since the carolingian period as we
established
actual formalized rules in english
didn't exist for centuries with
capitalization being quite haphazard
for instance in documents like the u.s
constitution and the declaration of
independence you see seemingly random
words capitalized capitalization in this
time was used basically to add emphasis
but in the late 18th and early 19th
centuries grammarians not amused by this
disorderly use of uppercase letters
created manuals defining when
capitalization should be used rules that
we basically follow today
and that's it thank you so much for
watching my video i hope you enjoyed it
and if you did please like comment and
subscribe and even share the video if
you want bye